be opportunistic when you see your big
chains come along you have to go for it
you got to take your shot otherwise
you're going to live the rest of your
life in regret and you're never going to
be able to build the business of your
dreams and the life of your dreams hi
I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help my
parents like to call me an aggressive
driver I prefer the term opportunistic
I'm not going to be the guy who's
honking his horn at you and who's
tailgating you but if I see a chance to
get into that next Lee and I move
forward I'm going to take it especially
when I'm driving my Vespa and you have
to be the same way with your business
you can't be stuck in traffic you got to
take opportunities to get ahead when
they come your way ask handler who was
the guy who put coca-cola on the map he
started off as a druggist he had his own
drug store and the founder of coca-cola
came to him and said try my new drink
it's called coca-cola and he tried it
and he loved it and you decided to buy
the company he saw an opportunity he
said this could be my day this could be
the thing that puts me on the map I'm
gonna go for it and he bought the
company from the inventor for two
thousand three hundred dollars and he
built it into one of the most recognized
companies in the world everybody knows
coca-cola you can't let opportunities
pass you by you can't get so so worked
up down in the trenches of running your
business that you miss huge
opportunities to take your business to
the next step when you see your shot you
got to go for it good luck for those are
you watching you like the video you know
the drill thumbs up please i love seeing
those come in and hey i want to hear
what you have to think please leave a
comment below it makes my morning every
time I see them come in and if you have
a question for your business leave it
below I'll answer for you on video
thanks guys we'll see you soon
you